hi reject nation Greg Alba here and I'm
John hey hey hey are you sick of us
talking about our upcoming live event
well get rid of vomit now because we
have a live event coming Saturday July
7th arena sin allowed on Sunset
Boulevard people live event meet and
greet q and A's but mainly film therapy
featuring movie clips that were choosing
to screen on the big screen at arena
Cinna lounge Brienne Chandler miss
movies herself is hosting Stacey Howard
will definitely be there because she
works at the theater and who knows other
people might come out to but it's gonna
be one hell of an event plugging
ourselves done but um Shh anyway I think
we're supposed to watch a trailer what
we don't do that unfriended dark web
whoo they premiered this on the actual
dark web the day before they dropped it
online so that's the thing that's smart
yeah that's smart
get that criminal Marcus yeah man I want
to go to the theaters opening night now
so you saw the first one yes I did not
see the first one but I heard it was
surprisingly good that's how I felt
about it I mean I rolled my eyes kind of
hard at the first trailer for that and
then I went in and I was like wow I am
surprisingly compelled by all that's
what blum house does best yeah all right
let's check this trailer out I am ready
to hit play oh there you go cyber cafe
that I've been working out and this
computer was sitting in the lost and
found for the last three or four weeks I
first friends
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they hear the sound effects too
damn
wait a minute like like you like in a
month apparently you know as scary as
that actually looked I don't think we
saw enough footage I think we need more
of the movie I don't feel like I saw
most of them died yet this is the one
guy who kind of looks like a brunette
Logan Paul you know if you seem to be
the last one standing I don't like that
I need the trade show me if he lives or
dies I don't want to have any mystery of
your gonna show most of it show all of
it that surprises me man
I was genuinely surprised I didn't see
the first one cuz I did think they look
really stupid and I maybe though I had
pretty good word of mouth obviously
garnder sequel so I'm like yeah maybe
it's worth checking out this knife T
it's not like gonna melt your face but
for what it is and what it's doing it
does it pretty well I hope when you're
editing this that when you say about
your face you throw in that image of
Raiders of the Lost Ark when their faces
are melt I will make sure to do the melt
your face melt your face Mel Mel Mel
fresh forever the last trailer was it's
just primarily cutting around to the
people in the room here they're going
through like different videos and a
whole bunch of different locations and
really exploring the dark web
simultaneously cutting around everyone
showing people getting killed off and
such so it looks more than just watching
a bunch of actors for an hour and a half
in front of their laptops this seems
like there's a lot of different change
of location and change of environment
and toying around even more with the
different images that come from a
computer and just the dark web is just
such a popular topic anyway that this
could get gross I hope it does I hope it
gets like gross yeah I feel like that's
one of the coolest things about this as
a sequel because the first movie has a
supernatural element and it's very
contained and this you're taking
something that is a bit more grounded in
reality the dark web the deep web is a
very sinister concept overall and you
know when you're down there you're with
people who know probably the ins and
outs of how computers really work yeah
so yeah like the expansion of that with
these videos are like that live feed in
her mom's hospital room that those kinds
of things open up the doors
what can be truly scary about this and
if someone's hacked into your computer
system because one part mate was like
well why don't you just secretly send a
text message I'm like but that is
usually connected to now yeah you know
you're on the same IP that ever they can
find all that yeah the trailer for the
first one made me go this looks stupid
this one made me go this is pretty
terrifying actually this is a scary
situation of being yeah and I'm not sure
love a sex chat rillettes I'm constantly
in oh man I can only imagine how I'm
sure they can find a way to do it you
know it isn't just you know watching a
bunch of different webcams cuz the first
one even has an element of that where
you are watching a screen recording
people are jumping between different
apps and stuff so the possibilities are
like semi endless as long as they're
computer related well I think for
unfriended for they should tone it down
even more should just be one person yeah
yeah go to the past when this all
started when you had like an IM chat
just open to yourself so you could take
notes yeah and you start talking back
but it's not really you know what's
going just one shot yeah one shot no
jump cuts one long take it's that is
like a Tyrone Magnus video I don't know
how they shoot these but they always
feel kind of interesting because the
webcam thing feels authentic so it
almost feels like a play in yeah the
interactions feel very authentic and
it's cool because the actors could have
their scripts on the computer try to see
my line but you keep mouthing it with
your words
close the pdms memorize I want to see
the outtakes yeah alright guys well a
lot of you requested that trailer we're
glad we got to check it out
you guys can't subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification melka
subscribe buttons don't mean [ __ ] and
you can check us out on patreon
full-length TV show reactions weekly Q&A
is music video coverage a bunch of other
fun goodies over there and arena Sun
lounge on Sunset Boulevard if you live
within a six hour driving distance to
that area you should come out and I will
high-five you and slap you on the butt
mm-hmm
guaranteed for the guys yeah because of
women will get me in trouble I mean
theoretically anybody could beat a
theoretically but come on we know
society